look we don't have much time I don't
know when he'll be back he cannot find
me here talking to you oh my god you're
never gonna believe me okay maybe you
should sit down
Isaac is dead though
strangled him he's dead Steph he's on
his way here right now so I need you to
believe me
he was so I've never seen him like that
before he was I mean I knew he had a
dark side but he acted like it was
nothing he strangled him and he acted
like it was nothing you know he's
capable of it I don't think he he made
it seem like Isaac wasn't even the first
person he's killed he's a sociopath how
could I not have seen that sooner we're
so stupid I thought he was my friend I
thought that he cared about people but
the reality is he doesn't care about
anyone he's a cold-blooded killer how
could I not have seen that or if I did
and I fell for him anyway then what does
that say about me